[Music]
four four
um welcome to the program i just put
a liquid eye shadow on my lips
so i look especially crazy today it's
very sparkly
yeah it's it's oh yeah it's bad it's bad
okay
okay i'm sorry i need to fix this oh
well it's fine just put more over it
hopefully you guys are listening to the
audio version of this and i'm watching
on youtube because i look like a whore
i look like a two-bit floozy uh i'm also
wearing uh
uh emily's fully roasted my horse shirt
that i'm wearing today
she's just jealous because oh the app
it's a
herd of horses running and with my
pendulous breasts it really looks like
they're running it looks like a 3d shirt
i can't take my eyes off it where'd you
get it
i got it um let me guess etsy let me let
me get yes i got it on etsy
and the jealousy in your voice is
frankly um upsetting
yeah yeah sorry i'm sorry i'm not drunk
dressed like a mime
like a french mine sorry i don't only
dress like marcel marceau wherever i go
emily only wears black and white striped
clothes it is
so intense it is like it's like your
go-to like you're just like someone take
me on a cruise
like you're always dressed
like you're on a vacation that no one
took you on
[Laughter]
like you're like i'm ready for the
hamptons driving out to one hills
yeah you're just you look you're you
dress like um caroline kennedy
and it's just i your spirit hasn't
broken and i i just appreciate that
about you
the spirit of a horse
i paint with all the colors of the wind
uh-huh and and i look like a jail bird
emily her earrings match they they both
look the same
my earrings haven't matched for years a
dinosaur there's a t-rex hanging from
your ear
one's a dinosaur and one's uh oh no i
think it fell out in the middle of night
uh but yeah a couple horseshoes you know
yeah trying to stand brand
yeah but yeah you're it's just so fun
you're just so put together it's like
chic and
um mentally
[Music]
i just don't know anyone that has their
whole wardrobe from etsy if you sell on
if you
sell on etsy whitney is bankrolling you
a thousand percent i'm upset i'm
completely obsessed with that c i can't
stop buying
well it's a i'm now between addictions
you know you're not between addictions
if you're addicted to etsy well no i was
the wheat edibles got a little out of
control and then i was like i can't do
this it's right it's 5 30. right
you can't get them on etsy yeah
i mostly quit weed edibles because i
couldn't find any on etsy
actually sometimes they'll be in there i
mean i don't know the way that etsy
packages are wrapped
they're all on wheat edibles it's just
like duct tape and like gauze
yeah i'm like is this wrapped in banana
bubble paper yeah it's
wrapped in band-aid it just like shows
up in your house and you just have to
like cut through it
and i always cut into the product i
purchased the bottom of this shirt is
shredded it's just shredded
not a fashion choice just fully couldn't
get it out
of the steel wool it was wrapped in it
always looks like a weird anthrax bomb
yeah well thank god you got it out so
there's always a nice treat inside
which brings me to uh i bought a little
purse on etsy that i was really proud of
little like little little like a little
black vintage purse like a little
little jimmy jam like how cute am i like
how cute are you
and i was uh no big deal invited to
paris hilton's birthday party
and i didn't bring a guest no i had a
guest but i was like i don't have anyone
that i
could bring here without embarrassing
you i would have brought
only one autograph book
oh my god you asking for autographs
it's so funny oh gosh oh and by the way
for those of you wondering benton is at
a doctor's appointment so
don't worry because as we were going all
i could think about were all the
ways he'd be roasting our clothes right
now and how we just got off so easy
i don't well first of all you went
pretty hard on you
i know next i'm going to come in with a
little red bow tie a little
red handkerchief oh well completely
white we need to get you like a um
a little what a little french beret
and uh okay so i get invited to paris
hilton's birthday party i have not been
out i've done stand-up we've toured a
little bit like i haven't been to like a
social event in like a year in
l.a you can't like they get shut down
like la's still shut down it's crazy
and so this is the purse if you guys are
not watching on youtube
i frankly pity you because i'm about to
show the world my purse this is really
the purse i carry
it's it's it's yellow
uh and it's clear it's clear it looks
like um
see-through highlighter well it looks
like uh uh like a
pool raft that hasn't been blown up yet
it it's a
it's i like all my purses to be clear so
i can see what's in it and then my
cosmetic bag everything's clear
yeah it's like an x-ray of my purse you
can see everything that's in here i got
i don't have any secrets yeah i don't
have any secrets you can go to a sports
stadium very easily
that's exactly what they're sold for so
i carry these like disgusting giant
i mean this is also like a vintage one
it's got like covered in stains
it's got like quaaludes and stains in it
it's got a little wallet attached to it
great so a pit pocket can just unzip it
it's still got an opening for a flip
phone i mean this is for a flip
that's actually amazing the pocket in
the front is for like an lg flip phone
where you do t9 texting i mean it's
and i have so many embarrassing things
in my purse i was like you know i'm
going to downsize i'm going to bring
i'm going to be cute i'm going to bring
a little purse to the party
if you had brought that to the party
they wouldn't have let you in i agree
i no it'd be like i'm not stealing if i
steal you'll know
i got no i got i can't you can't steal
anything right this is a daytime bag
this is a a this is a um remember lady
luck
no she was uh the powerball lady and i'm
obsessed with commercials from the 90s
oh yeah
get the crazy one yeah this is some shit
that she would carry this is just like
uh you can also see a prescription
bottle in there so yeah yeah i'm jealous
um that's if i need to sedate you at
some point because because i don't i
don't need any more of your
lip if you start getting out of hand so
this is how
i roll i don't know what to tell you say
what you want but i'm prepared for
pretty much any pair of socks wool socks
wool socks
and i was like i'm also going to doubt
because there are some things in here i
just don't need to come in and
you don't need wool socks at a party i
mean look
i mean you clearly don't know how to
party yes i do have prescriptions in
here
i have like used masks in here my the
main
um piece to resistance in my purse
are my driving gloves so they're not
they're nude colored
like they're so disgusting they look
just like a nasty old like bandage but
it's not because i need like a grip
driving because i'm such a professional
like
sporty driver i just um my biggest fear
that was drilled into me
by my mom and aunts when i was a kid was
like your hands aged first
that's true and this your day your
decolletage
oh day college i'm sorry you're you're
you're you're you're you're you're
you're you're you're pronouncing that
yes there
and so these are my driving gloves
they're very sexual and they're mostly
to stop
aging in my hands but they do look like
i um a skin people alive and wear
suits of that's exactly what it is yes
it's a little hannibal lecter so yeah
yeah i'm like i'm gonna downsize i don't
need to go embarrass myself at this
party
we're gonna put it in a little black
section so many other ways you wouldn't
make it i'm basically audrey hepburn
look at me in my little tiny black
purse i've got like one lip gloss one
mint
one mint my driver's license you know
like those tiny purses fit like four
things you have to make a lot of big
decisions
yeah um i walk into the party okay i see
james charles who's a beauty influencer
he's a very famous he's like 25. yeah
he'll hate that i don't really
so uh when i was able to to uh
regroup my sight after becoming blind
with jealousy
right i storm over to him because i have
this storm overdoing a storm over to him
i have this problem where i think the
only
way i can socialize is being of use to
people
and i have this really uh uh
overwhelming need to like mother the
next generation in this business i have
noticed
even though i'm not even in his business
i'm not even in the beauty and but like
i i don't even have any advice for him
and i see yeah i like stormed up to him
i'm like are you okay do you have a good
lawyer
like i it's wild he's like is this joan
rivers like he's like who is this lady
like i'm just like is everything okay
or you know how's your lawyer doing let
me see your taxes sign your checks like
i'm just like do you have a good time
he's like what's a check like yeah
literally he was like i only um
make bitcoin like what are you talking
about and
i'm so focused on him and i put my purse
down and then there's all these amazing
people there and i'm like talking
it was like so fun and everyone was so
nice and then
the moment in the party where you
realize you've misplaced your purse oh
and you're like stomach falls through
your butt couldn't
couldn't tell you yeah and i and when
you lose your push to party i can't
think about anything else not 100
it feels like a limb is missing a lim
and i'm talking to people
right i'm like looking around them and
i'm looking on the and so they think i'm
on like
adderall or which my personality is
already
not the most focused i don't i'm not
known for like
you know what people have noticed that
yeah i i'm not known for finishing every
sentence i start right right right
as it is and so i'm like so distracted
and
i realized right away i look like that
person at the party that's like looking
for the more famous person
and i but i'm really just looking for my
purse i don't want people to think that
i'm like
looking through them for someone else
right right right so i had to just go
hey i can't find my person i'm really
freaked out
yeah and so then everyone starts to try
to help me look for my purse which is
even more embarrassing
it's the worst because they weren't a
bunch of hollywood assholes that were
like good luck with that they're like oh
let's help you find it like
this poor woman needs a shit if we lost
our purse it wouldn't matter
and the best part about it is they're
like what does your purse look like
there's
50 black purses sitting around see what
this would have been the tiny take the
bright yellow one
can i i was right uh with the giant no
with the giant hertz trash bag well it's
good because no one will ever steal that
either
exactly so i betrayed myself and my
values by getting
a freaking black purse so everyone there
is like well what does it look like
yeah and i'm like it's black and like
okay what kind of person what designer
i'm like dude it's the one that's not
hermes it's it's literally i'm like the
aldo one
the aldo one you know the one it's got a
silver buckle
like the the pleather uh coach one
oh my god they're like oh we thought
that was trash yeah like we threw that
out
we threw that away and so
it's like everyone's got these beautiful
purses everyone's got and i'm
also you know like when you're trying to
get your luggage at the
uh the wheel after the carousel but how
every
piece of luggage looks like your luggage
because you just need to find your
language
i'm like picking up people's purses like
these are famous people
right these are people like that have
numerous restraining orders against
i'm picking up people's purses they're
like ma'am can we help you be rexa is
like do you need something
uh and so it was just so funny because
everyone's like what kind of purse is it
and i was just like uh it's the um it's
like nine west they're like what's that
like it was big in the 90s um check out
my feet i have a bunch of corns from
their shoes
uh it was so embarrassing and then what
i realized was
it's like it was it's actually kind of a
good conversation starter to be like
okay i'm trying to find my person
everyone's got a scavenger hunt
right i'm also in that moment remember
like i have
blue hair and there's certain things
that when you have blue hair
you just can't do you can't be late you
can't lose your purse
you can't scream at people you can't
scream at people like you just
um i'm already on thin ice right i walk
in the door people
already think i have a meth problem and
so losing my purse it was like
there was everyone's like it's okay
honey and i was like no i'm not i don't
need you like her meth must be in there
she needs to find it i know she's having
the dts
she's having withdrawals we gotta find
drawers i
and it was just like it was it was just
so dumb and i was so embarrassed but
everybody was so cool about it
that i i spent most of the night like in
the bushes yeah
looking for my purse and then i was like
trying to retrace my steps through her
house
right so i'm just storming through her
house looking i just look like i'm
stealing
i look like i'm i'm glad you didn't
bring me as a guest yes
humiliating it was bad and then the
person that helped me
so it was such a like bad romantic
comedy moment like katherine heigl would
have passed on this movie
so this guy walks up to me super
handsome dude he's like hey
what's up and i was like i can't find my
purse and like i didn't know
he wasn't like iggy azalea or someone
like so famous hey buddy like
we seem like we're both right and we're
all the same
yeah like you know you know what aldo is
yeah yeah
like you've been to bb yeah yeah yeah
you know bandage dress
and so i'm like hey and then he's like
you don't recognize me and i was like
ugh because i am at the point in my life
in this business where i
i do introduce myself to people that i
have dated for about six months five
years ago
you introduced yourself to people you've
dated i i've i
there's times where i just you're like
oh hey what's up and your brain goes is
this person famous
do i know this person from my oh we
dated yeah there's
those have i would love to have dated
enough people to lose track of them
um no you don't that's true there's not
enough valtrex in the world
uh but no remember there was an episode
of sex in the city where kim cattrall
she said i fucked everyone in new york
remember yes and she fucked the same
person again
and didn't realize it and didn't realize
it until they were having sex was like
we fucked before
that's horrifying but it wasn't i just
was like my brain
i always assume you dated i i just
always assume you rejected me at some
point
um uh and so he comes up to me and he's
like my name is hunter march and i'm
like
oh fuck so hunter
is the co-host of paris holds podcast
and he when liza koshy was on this
episode
she was talking about a date or on the
show she was talking about a date that
she went on and
it like didn't and i was just being me
you know
loud mouth dumbass just whatever and so
i'm like who's this tool like what and i
was just like roasting the date and
reading that
right i talked about like 40 minutes on
the podcast we were just joking i didn't
even know the guy
i was like this guy's a tool yeah like
he's i'm just
you know right being me just trying to
make sure no one ever gets close to me
right right uh
and uh and he comes up he's like i'm
hunter you talked about me
about me on your podcast for about 40
minutes i was like thanks for watching
hunter
how's it going so you're a fan of the
show big fan of the show when you're on
autograph do you want a photo or
and i was like oh fuck i was like dude i
am
so sorry i do not think you're a tool
can you please help me find my purse
and he was just like you are such an at
like i just was like you must think i am
the biggest asshole
and so he's helping me find my purse
he's being so nice
so gracious um and uh and then
we do not find it it is not it is not
found that's insane well because you
know that day that
that or the moment when you lose your
person you start going like what's in
there
uh-huh like like two ativan
likes a couple nyquil gel caps like my
license is in there when they open it
they'll know
right that it was me i just love the
thought of you going through famous
people's purses being like is this mine
is this mine
is this mine is this mine and i'm being
like it says gucci on it
it's not yours i should have known i
have a gucci one with one c
it's from etsy one scene two eyes i mean
it's just like
i should have known it wasn't mine it
said celine on the side
pretty obvious it belonged to someone
named celine
and so uh he was so helpful
so then it's like 11 30. we still have
not found it
uh uh and then i had a car
take me and the car left so now i don't
have a car
i can't find my purse i still have blue
hair oh uh
and it now just looks like i'm trying to
linger at the party
you know what i mean i uh we're new
friends and
i'm everyone's going well you're not
friends anymore i mean no no i will not
be asked back
i feel like next year i will not i will
not make the cut but like nikki hilton's
left
right right yeah yeah yeah time you go
and i it's like me and her fiance and
i'm just like pretending and i'm like no
i'm just gonna
it was such a nightmare and then hunter
got an uber and i was like can i
get in your uber can i get a ride was
your phone in your purse
it was not charged no i had the phone
but i couldn't get an uber i was just
like the fucking
i i i walked into a party paris hilton's
house was some of the most
interesting i made it about me within 10
seconds that's a real talent it is a
skill
that i that is a skill literally he's
just like especially on someone's
birthday
imagine being hunter this guy who was
like you just be now i have to drive you
home
like i was just like dude i'm so sorry
and so
uh but then they did find my purse the
next day the next day
they found it yeah they found it like
the next day where was it they said it
was in like a palm tree or something
i don't even i just chucked it up there
and but the best part is when you can't
find your purse or your phone
because you've misplaced it the moment
you go guys did someone
someone hiding it guys yeah yeah guys is
this a joke a prank and everyone's like
is there someone from the bling ring
here no no literally
that moment you're like do you guys have
it yeah like yeah
party we're all planning a prank on you
with your purse
you fucking narcissist like the where
your mind goes
right you know just the franticness i i
uh
i sympathize with you anyway i just
thought i would share uh with you guys
my f what happened in my first
outing out of the house uh uh great
gardens little edie and big eat you
decided to leave and it didn't go so
well everybody is relearning
socialization
yes that's the other thing we're rusty
i'm a rusty and i also realized
like no one else wanted to talk about
kovit i thought that's all anyone want
to talk about because all my friends are
comedians and we're just when are we
gonna be able to tour we're
like like most people i'm like so did
you have it what's going on yeah are you
the covet and they're like
we don't talk about that 24 hours a day
yeah yeah you're back in life
yeah you know i feel like i've been
sequestered into this like bubble where
everyone's just like
does it have the spikes right right the
spike like you know
right right yeah little red spikes yeah
the blood clots in germany did you hear
about that yeah
and they're just like you're like my
cognitive function's off can you tell i
know
i saw katie couric there and uh you did
yeah katie was
so cool i know when ashley was leaving i
was like let's talk about the news she's
like
i'm socializing i'm just i'm rusty
i'm very rusty and i think being on a
podcast or hosting this podcast for a
long time i'm like you need to ask
interesting yeah
all the time yeah yeah you know so i
recorded a couple good podcasts there
that uh
i feel for everyone at that party yeah
i'd like to just say i'm sorry and um
i won't see you next year that was when
she thought that you could be friends
yes this is before she knew that i was a
hot ass mess
okay so peak tea one of our sponsors
uh i got i
i use this product uh i know you do very
like seriously i watch you but last time
on the podcast i talked about it in an
ad i i didn't misspeak i just you know
me
got overly excited overly excited that's
my brand
so i'm just gonna show you guys real
quick because i do this every morning
anyway
uh this is how i get my sparkling
dazzling energy and personality
is we're gonna take it away from her the
irony is all the sponsors that i
screw up the ads are the ones i actually
use
um okay i'm gonna put a little above my
peak tea my turmeric peak tea
i put it in my water this is how to
properly use it just so
that it falls in water we don't get sued
and nobody gets in trouble
so it dissolves in water instantly look
how easy
so easy handled also i'm going to show
you i have a little surprise for you
oh great here we go whenever emily has a
packaging yeah oh that's the peak t o to
t box
okay emily here we go
when you open it the music plays like a
creepy music box
uh creepy that i used to put my suicide
notes in when i was a kid you remember
the one you'd open and there'd be a
little ballerina just circling around
just like a sad and then she'd fall off
and it was just a spring like before
before we knew that just ballet was just
anorexic girls with uh toes that look
like curly fries
look how beautiful um okay so couple
things we have a lot of glazer on the
show
we do a lana glazer
so we have a lot of glazer on the show
today so we should shut up
we should shut zip it our slut mouths so
that we can hear
alana glazer i don't have a slip mount
be so charming
so smart i'm such a fan so incisive such
a fan
i'm actually the interview was i got
anxious shocker because she's so um
present and there's no confident
and there's not an anxious energy coming
from her that's what i didn't recognize
and it was it's it's so alien to me to
not
really like to spew so she is just so
clear and she's thoughtful and she
thinks and
uh about what she's gonna say before
she's and she has exciting news
she has very exciting news on the
podcast um
but i was very uh like
manicky yeah um shocker i'm
i'm really listening back to this
episode i was so uh
uh delighted to hear her talk and so
embarrassed to hear me talk
because she was so eloquent and
interesting and incisive
and then when i started talking i
started realizing like i should stop
talking
and let her talk but it's impossible but
then i would cut myself off
so and i need to stop saying do you know
what i mean
i do that too it's grading but no it's
like bad it's like no i mean i mean i
didn't notice that really
yeah oh gosh um alana glazer you've seen
her on a little show called broad city
god so good which is still
the most favorite meme show in my text
messages i mean
every text is her or abby jacobs and
broad city yeah that show is alive and
well even though i think they just did
their last season on comedy central
she had a stand-up special called the
planet uh is burning on amazon
it is uh and it is burning and uh you
know
we talked a lot about like this business
and how it's changing
and it was it was kind of a more serious
conversation like
that it's a different side of her yeah i
thought was really cool yeah because i
was expecting she's a business woman
right i was i was expecting like goofy
goofy and it was so
not like that and it was awesome but the
fact that she can go back and forth from
that and when she's performing she's
you know can be you know funny and silly
and outlandish and and
such a brilliant physical comedian and
then when you sit down with her she's
just like a business woman
right and she's so well spoken yeah you
can be both
and um that's just cool
i learned a lot from her yeah i learned
a lot from her
and uh she's doing a lot of cool stuff
yeah if you want to
make money in any business listen to
this yeah you know
she's also just really conscious and
really thoughtful and
i don't know she uses her platform you
know what i mean yes yes
i like to put people on pedestals is
that the same thing
is using your platform like you use your
platform
for horses
jealous and oh yeah do you guys want to
see how i'm wearing a horse shirt see if
you guys are not watching on the youtube
you're missing out because i'm wearing a
horse shirt
it's bright pink that looks like if i
jiggle my boobs enough it looks like
horses are getting
like they're running it looks like
they're running with broken legs because
my boobs are fake and they
they don't go up too much so it looks
like they're hobbling it looks like and
might
look like my stripes are waving
yours looks like um i'm wearing stripes
yeah yours just gave me a
migraine uh i love you guys alana glazer
enjoy uh she is a delight we also shot
in a different room so you're gonna see
a different
set it's my uh what is going to be my
bedroom
um subscribe to the youtube if ben let's
see all the things benton would do if he
were here
but he's at the doctor's appointment he
would say like subscribe
follow us on the good for you podcast
also we
are getting such amazing guests and
doing so much stuff sometimes we come
out on thursday we try to come out on
wednesday but sometimes you know what we
like to keep you on your toes we like to
keep you on your toes
and i'm just learning how to upload on
youtube so be patient
uh keep on your toes your camel toes but
if you were just to subscribe to the
youtube we you wouldn't we wouldn't we
wouldn't have this problem because you
guys go where is it you know what i
learned about ring that little bell
you press that little bell you can ring
my bell
ring my mouth i don't think i'm a better
singer than i i was told
i disagree uh
ring my bell that's what i i sing that
to men as they're having sex with me
you better bring my bell and she doesn't
have sex that often no and it's because
i wear a collar with a bell on it
and she knees okay
i love you guys enjoy a lot of glazer uh
tour dates
real quick uh you know
whitneycomings.com do people go to
websites anymore
um on their phones yeah uh
whitneycompanies.com i am coming to
texas san antonio oh i can't wait for
san antonio i've never been there
you're not invited spokane washington
april 15th the 17th we just added a
couple more shows we're doing shows at
like
three and four in the afternoon so early
bird special
bring your flask uh uh san antonio april
22nd to 24th
uh texas is open brea california
may 7th and 8th we'll probably add some
shows right outside like an hour outside
l.a
houston texas may 13th to 15th dallas
texas may
20th to 22nd tempe arizona june 4
through 6.
birthday weekend emily um
someone don't put that in my calendar so
i have an excuse uh baltimore maryland
june 10th
through 12th actually pronounced
baltimore baltimore baltimore baltimore
downshore baltimore uh
and uh uh text me 818-239-7527
that is the text app that if you text me
we will give you updates
we love you guys alana glazer bye so
cool
i'm loving this wild this is kind of
good right god you're such a fucking
builder i fucking love it yeah and
you're always like ready to talk shop i
love it
it's amazing it's amazing i feel like
we're going right yeah i feel like i
know all this stuff about the business
that's no longer applicable
[Laughter]
and i have to pass it on as quickly as
possible well
the business changes you know what
actually it's like because you know when
we first like had that dinner in new
york
you were like saying yeah i'm the
original hi guys
and i i like didn't realize you were
like
more of like a vj you know because i
know you as a comedian yeah
um so you do know this like sort of
antiquated
90s like talking about sweetheart like
fucking ass
slapping and you fucking made it through
bitch you
survived that shit but the thing is it's
not different it just
looks different the way that you know
mass incarceration is slavery
it's just like this you know it's just
taken it's the another generation so the
things that
and i i think you continue clearly
clearly you continue to analyze
and update the operating system or
whatever but it's like it's
it is still the same it is in a lot of
way and it's interesting and you're the
perfect person to get into this with
because it's such a dangerous territory
to talk about in terms of my own
internalized
misogyny sexism what's appropriate it it
sometimes takes it
one of the youngins around here to go
like yeah it's eight o'clock we're going
home
100 no it's eight o'clock what do you
mean we order dinner and we work so
midnight
hundreds and they're like no we're going
we have plans with our families and
we're like oh
so you'll come after i mean at 100
i mean i this weekend i was like working
on this presentation thing and
i was like oh i'll just send it to my
assistant and i was like oh no it's a
saturday like
those days are over i'm i'm 33
and i'm just to mark like my whatever
and i'm like cut between where i'm like
boundaries are really important and it's
like well why are you shouting that and
it's like because i
i'm it's not in my bones yet but i'm
trying and it's going i'm setting a
boundary now i need
you to just do the rest of the work
because i can't i'm not fully ready to
do it myself so
the mental emotional work to retain the
boundary you mean yeah or just
i'm giving it to you i'm i'm passing you
the ball
uh-huh you know what i mean i'm saying
that's that's what i do where like my
assistant is like
amazing boundaries like the like our
company is
uh it's really amazing how we are like
enacting these
healthy boundaries and i'm like i think
i tell her like good night so that she
stops working but then i don't it's hard
we have to like heal ourselves
by you know um
it's a dynamic so you met grace
downstairs
she's 24 she's uh she's new on the team
and she uh she uh
the first day she was here she there was
like a plastic bag she's like where do
you put your plastic bags and i was like
uh and i was like i literally um where
is the plastic bag like i literally was
like
you know when we threw him out the
window when i was a kid
you know what i mean it's really the and
then it was lunchtime i was like oh you
know i'm shoveling like candy in my
mouth
and she's like i'm gonna grab something
to eat and i'm like cool i fully expect
her to just like jam a gogurt down or
throw like a deep throw to go green
right i turn around she's fully cooking
an omelette at the stove
and i was just like in since when
amazing
amazing she's like i'm not doing this
yeah and it's also not even conducive to
good work
and what i found that made me
this is the sick way to get healthy i
was so afraid of um
reinforcing negative stereotypes about
women that i was like you can't be
frazzled you can't be hysterical you
like just because i don't want them to
have that on you
mm-hmm it wasn't i was doing it for
myself that you were saying it to them
you mean
no just like the way that i was working
like crazy frazzled but
yes yes i was like people already think
i'm emotional and histrionic and
hysterical
and don't deserve to be here and can't
control my emotions
i have to just over correct and then it
kind of becomes muscle memory
uh-huh whatever gets you there over
correction is so is so huge
and like sometimes i uh
like 24 25 year olds will help me not be
so
over correcting about race i'm so over
correcting that it's like
racist or it's just like crazy where i'm
like
i don't know i'm like um you know in my
head i'm just like you stupid white
bitch you stupid my bitch you think you
know
bitch and it's like this isn't this
isn't healthy and it's not correct
and it's like i'm like i don't know
cutting myself
short by so much where you have to be
able to just
fucking be to you know like
having trouble existing i guess and also
like my whiteness
i i'll cut out a slice of my existence
because of
my whiteness and it's like i don't know
we have to be present and exist
in order to embody the change of what it
means to be a white person
like you have to you know it doesn't
help to be so filled with shame that
you're like
nuts putting your shit on somebody else
not
um giving yourself the space to be like
every like all these different types of
people
are here on on this planet you know um
it's hard to it's really hard that what
you're saying is so powerful because i
spent so much my time trying to figure
out what shame
is productive and what shame is a
liability because shame serves a really
important purpose
in society you know we feel shame to not
do bad things like it's worked in a lot
of ways but if we're living in shame
we're frozen we're paralyzed we're not
functioning optimally
and we're not thinking clearly it's a
tricky one yeah and it's also like
we deserve to have a little shame we
should have some for sure and it's
it's a volume thing it's a duration
thing like how long do you let it last
you know and when do you move on and
become more productive and healthier and
like the healthier
the healthier we are as individuals the
healthier the whole is
that's a fucking tough one as
i've been ingrained to self-deprive
minimize
put myself last i thought that was like
nice especially as a boss
i'll go home last i'll do you know what
i mean i'm gonna martyr myself
but then i'm sick all the time and i'm
teaching people
and it's it's like opposite because that
i might keep adjusting this the um
leading by example is so powerful
and it is the way to do it in everything
parenting people and everything
and because i want to go like oh i can
lecture you all day long on how to do
this right
but it's so incongruous with the way i'm
behaving and that's like a really like
thoughts
um i try to like out
think my feelings often and it's like
sure you can exactly like lecture and
talk about the right way to do things
but like if you're not
doing it and enacting it with your body
it's kind of just like remember like
being in school and they would like
teach shit and it's like this is fucking
meaningless
you know what i mean like what you were
learning was to sit in a chair for 50
minutes
right right and like fake it or whatever
like my
my best friend is a um psychiatrist and
i was like
we were best friends through his medical
school and he was like learning all this
shit and it meant
nothing until he was like in his
residency applying it
and then it was like oh my god i
remember i learned this but it doesn't
doesn't mean anything until you
do it and you got into a position bless
you excuse me
a position negative negative
negative um just negative person um and
you got
into position of power so quickly and we
went from like
playing around and we it's sort of we
have this wonderfully inappropriate
business in a lot of ways
and then all of a sudden you're thrust
into a position of a boss where all of a
sudden
you walking into a room whatever your
energy is is the energy of the room
yeah they look too wild so if you're
walking i'm like
i'm saying that everyone's like well
okay if she's stressed we're all fucking
stressed yeah so
so that's just so much pressure like did
that come naturally to you
is that's when you still and like also
the stuff put on us as young women like
what we were
um seen as probably incapable of
or um just taken for granted well
they've done it before
like there's no um you know just the way
that we problem solved and then it's
like
solve it solve it solve it and it's like
help or get more money to solve the
problem like
why do i have to continue this you know
what i mean like what i have to continue
with this
standard that i've set for myself um
and then you get in there and you're
trying to make decisions and you're like
well this system's so broken
i can't hire the women i want because
there's no child care and we're shooting
till midnight
you know i'm saying i can't even get
like you as you're trying to
make healthy decisions you realize
you're working within such a byzantine
backwards system you're like well we
just need to fix the system
before you know this is such a and that
like comes back to the embodying thing
because it's like you can't really fix
the whole system
from the outside you have to like embody
it piece by piece from the inside
and it's just like and there's unions
and there's jobs and i also struggled
this is like so embarrassing to say but
i'd struggle with the first time i was
boss i was like
there's older men that have been doing
this so much longer than me they
probably fucking hate me
they think they don't know and like i
feel i'm so conditioned to make sure
men feel comfortable and not threatened
by me or
not embarrass them that i wasted so much
time and energy whereas they just want
clarity
just tell me just it's like i'm the one
bringing the feelings into it they're
fine i'm projecting my shit onto them
because i'm like daddy daddy do you love
me and they're just like
can we just just tell me blacker what
color is the couch
i don't care yeah you know you know
they've all worked with monsters in the
90s like i'm the nicest person they've
ever
been with and sometimes you realize
being nice isn't nice because you're
really just not being
clear you know so like um maybe just be
clear
and even if you change your mind later
that's okay right
you just have to be say blue and then if
later you need to go actually
and walk them through y but i wanted to
like empower everyone to make everyone
feel
and i just was being indecisive and i
didn't realize that sometimes being nice
isn't nice being clear is being nice
that took me so long because i didn't
want anyone think i was a bitch or a
cunt or bossy or entitled or
or like being decisive is kind and being
nice is just like what
you know like we're not fucking we're
not dating just give me the answer
i think of also like the like white
suburbs i grew up in
on long island as like everybody's like
really nice
you know and it's like no you're not
like we're not allowing
other types of people to live here it's
not nice you know passive aggressive
this is
like there's a result like like you're
homophobic and racist
you're not nice just because you like
smile at someone passing
at king collin or whatever yeah what are
you doing when no one's watching yeah
that to me is how you define nice
yeah i also i just want to bring up our
relationship because i'm kind of
obsessed with it
love it i'm like obsessed with our
friendship
me too i you're uh you are fascinating
to me and you're
infinite you have infinite internal
resources
that is so kind and i'm i'm
gonna say thank you to set an example
that you receive
uh compliments and don't fight them it's
really hard for me i'm trying to show
this next generation you don't
have to self-deprecate and argue with
people when they say something nice i
just remember
being so gross right away and being
because
it's funny to hear you say gross you
know what it's reminding me of is like
human
okay i'm doing analysis which is like 40
and like on the couch three times a week
45 minutes three times i'm obsessed
i'm obsessed can you make it a podcast
it's it's my only question
can we get rich off this are you
recording it oh that's so brilliant and
like yeah let's let's do it
um have it for a documentary you know
what i mean because in fact i actually
have been thinking about
um asking my my best friend inti who's
this psychiatrist
um if he and i should like would you
want to just do like a limited series
because he does analysis
and is now becoming an analyst and got
me into it and we're very much
it's incredible it's incredible and the
all the the only difference is the
frequency
and the training is a little bit
different but that's not frequency what
does that mean
three times a week oh the amount of time
you do it yes and it's just like a brain
frequency
um it's just like um
the difference between putting your body
into that space and time three times a
week versus once a week
and i just find my analyst continually
saying i like the frequency brings up
the like
themes more often such that it's like
jesus fucking christ i say to him this
whole thing is mom dad life death mom
dad life death
it's just all the same shit aloneness
versus loneliness
money you know just the same fucking
shit
and like holding your own shape versus
spilling all out
all over everybody and um
human like when you say we were gross
right away it's like we were fucking
human we were messy we were not
within a system of like set like you
know what i mean like a script we were
just
human and it's also like i feel this
obligation and maybe it's codependent
and and you just said spilling all over
the place something i'm really working
on is restraint of pen and tongue
which is uh not everyone needs to know
everything all the time
[Music]
restraint of pen and tongue not pen and
teller not
random i would like pen and tell her to
have some restraint
uh but i feel like teller has a lot of
shame he doesn't speak at all right
you know what's so crazy is like it's so
new like i was doing this uh
whatever bit on the road when kovac shut
it all down
um shut like touring down but like we're
i think i i was saying on stage we're
past
the point of peak consciousness
consciousness is like
the fucking beach everybody's like you
know fucking or like
brushing each other's hair whatever the
fuck you know we're way
past that shit but i'm not god who who
am i to say what's better or worse but
it's like
this is new consciousness that's for
fucking sure i mean covid
this global situation where the
intersection
of like this thing that's happening
right now medically and then
all the intersectional systematic
truths that came from it it's this is
like a new
consciousness so like no shit like
puking out all your feelings is
different than it was one fucking year
ago
i mean it's so new and like social media
you're supposed to share but it's like
actually you're supposed to package
ideas in a new way you're not really
supposed to share and it's not authentic
it's not
i mean i don't know you're supposed to
be authentic by like
you can be authentic without being
reckless for sure
and and like authenticity i think is
just like a
a goal of all the different
practices anybody whatever the combo of
practices somebody needs to get through
the fucking day
it's not really like a about um
presentation or a litmus test like
authentic
you pass i'm like kylie jenner is
probably
being authentic yeah to herself yeah she
like just named her dog
kevin you don't know just like
yeah that's that's didn't she trademark
the phrase rise and shine and she got it
she went in and she's saying rise and
shine to her
daughter stormy and then it was like on
tick-tock and she trademarked it
unbelievable a phrase we've been saying
for easily 400 years
oh it's about it's just like honest
good for you there's also something you
were just talking about like being like
at work and don't be emotional don't be
frazzled and like sometimes i'm like
sometimes i'm like poor white men you
know like they're
they they're like caught in this lie
themselves and there's not like the
marginalized
space for them to be human
and you know that's why every tv
that's why 99 of content and art has
been made about their experience
so that they have the space to explore
it or whatever but you know like
when you hear a noise in the house and
like the man is supposed to go down and
risk his life when it's like well
wouldn't the two of us
together be better at like figuring out
some emergency
problem or something it's just like why
you're some we
don't like we objectify their bodies in
a different way our bodies are
objectified so fuck yours is to kill you
yeah and i'm like you're not a killer
you're on
instagram like i am and like you're like
lazy you're using
beard oil yeah he's gonna slip right off
you when he punches you in the face
like this is not yeah a thing oh god i
had something i want to bring up with
you so badly and i just forgot it
but yeah i mean yeah it is like um uh
and i'm so impressed with you and your
boundary coming in
by the way you guys scheduling this we
talk about this all the fucking time
and i uh as we schedule this she said i
have from one to three i have to leave
it three i have to leave it three
i it's in writing it's i and then she
comes in she's like let me know when
it's 2 15. like
alana's getting out of here and and i i
say all the time now
when business when you get on the phone
you say hey guys this call should only
be about 20 minutes
you always set a time for the call i'm
also psyched because
i was very trepidatious asking you to do
this because
i as david spade says um doing a
friend's podcast is like jury duty at
this point
it's it's just a countdown like you're
gonna have to there's no
and i've been on the other side like
sarah silverman bless her heart at her
uh at her yearly party she just has a
sign that says
no solicitor podcast that is so
funny i just heard about this party from
ike baron holtz and i was like
i don't live in l.a i know you can't
change fans it's in august the rooftop
part
it's like every august i mean probably
not it didn't happen last year or
whatever but uh
but i always am so trepidatious about
asking people that i
love and care about sitting for podcasts
because i'm like i know this is going to
fuck up our friendship but i
know how much people are going to
benefit from this conversation yeah and
also like
start a podcast you have no friends left
but a great interview right right
that's why i'm like i shouldn't ask my
friend inti but it would just i think it
would just be him and i but
we need more forward facing
psychologists and doctors
we need to okay great they need i agree
they need to start talking because
uh twitter cannot be right um a doctor's
office anymore
and i love it and also it's like they
don't make money
right you can make money on ad sales
right benefit right right right i
i'm free medicine if it's just he and i
it's just a more in-depth thing and it's
not me asking everybody or whatever that
is so
here's the thing we're taking we're
trying to talk about free healthcare
we're not going to get it right this
it's going to take a minute with
podcasts getting doctors on
i mean dr boris who's downstairs uh who
did our test really i have them on the
podcast i asked them all these coveted
questions
it's like this could be a form of free
information
in the meantime totally you know what
i'm saying but i like to have doctors on
the podcast and then ask people hey do
you guys need any medical advice let me
save you a trip to the doctor that's
awesome
send me pictures of your mole you know
oh my goodness we're taking a little
break in this emotional rollercoaster to
talk to you about
stitch fix yeah no stitch fix is not
referring to
the scars on my boobs uh
from my friends it's not about that it's
about clothing
hand selected clothing by expert stylist
delivered right to your door
look at this website knows i've seen it
i mean
you basically go in look at this you
take a test you tell them kind of
the the what you like uh
and they will deliver you hand-picked
items
and look how cute everyone looks see i
can't be trusted to
if it was me buying my own clothes i
would just buy i'm wearing a horse shirt
right now now you still if you if you're
watching you know why i need stitch fix
i'm wearing a uh a blue men's shirt with
uh
dude brown colored horses on it yeah
dylas are cards poker
i don't know how pokers works it's like
a it's shaped like an
a tommy bahama hawaiian shirt with just
uh
the only pattern left in the bargain bin
at michaels the feel of vacation the
look of having no friends
i mean i really do need help stitchfish
will help you you'll pay just 20
styling fee for each box which gets
credited towards the pieces that you
keep there are no hidden fees
ever chic look at all these clothes they
send you things that
go together also because like i'll buy
something you can wear once with one
thing
this is like stuff that like you can
wear to work and then we're out and then
you know they all match each other
it's very helpful no subscription
required so like if i got that shirt in
the mail i'd be like cancel my
subscription
but you'd be like keep them coming and
both of us would be
fine no subscriptions are required i
like it because they put full outfits
together whereas i'm like
i just buy pieces of all the
personalities i want and they don't do
that here and they're
also available in the uk which is really
cool for our uk listeners
get started today at stixx get started
today at stitchfix.com hold on
real quick we're gonna oh wait oh what
we
well i'm gonna let you slide on that one
what happened
the green copy but also emily this might
not be for you because they don't send
wedding dresses
yeah they do send for kids pretend to
get knocked up you can get a stitch fix
box
okay you guys sometimes we just go a
little too crazy with the ads so we do
have to read
uh the a certain copy correctly
right they don't know it's green but yes
it's screened up we see it on the screen
get started today at stitchfix.com
whitney you'll get 25
off when you keep everything in your fix
that's stitchfix.com
whitney for 25 off when you keep
everything in your fix stitchfix.com
whitney okay this is entire ad uh is for
emily because no one needs
better help more than mwah after
uh reuniting with me for the past two
months
[Laughter]
well that is beautiful so better help is
um
online therapy it is not it is
professional counseling done securely
and
safely it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help they'll match you to a
professional
license these are people that went to
school to understand psychology these
aren't like
like people that are like i'm a life
coach now these are like
adults with degrees that know how to
help you with your
thoughts yeah these services are
available to clients worldwide you can
log into your account anytime send a
message to your counselor they'll get
back to you
thoughtfully and responsibly you can do
it from the back from the bathroom of
your office if you're having a bad day
you can do it from your bathtub tell
them why you're crying while you're
crying in the shower
they don't like that yeah phone case
all right uh emily's going to read the
green she messes up she gets a bean
visit their website this podcast is
sponsored by a better help and good for
you listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
whitney damn you got it i don't stop
winking at the camera i literally can't
it's you do it a lot
it's wild it's like everything i have
you're like george costanza when he got
that grapefruit juice in his eye
how do you protect your time oh my gosh
um
i'm like uh
i'm working on protecting my time
more i'm not great at it i
well this is actually what i want to say
is like i've been here for like five or
six months in la and i've been wanting
to have this conversation
and you and i get down to business you
know so quickly that i'm like
it makes sense you know what i mean it's
like i think we both have trouble like
relaxing and hanging for pleasure so it
it kind of
i've been wanting to do this so thank
you for having me i love you and i
remember when i
i first i uh when phoebe robinson and i
sort of became friends we sort of
we sort of emailed and and and hung out
in the first time okay so who's your age
like we got right into it and this
person shouldn't be taking you shouldn't
be commissioning this
i feel this responsibility and i'm not
even that much older than you got
but i feel this responsibility like
you've been in the business for a long
time you also were like so hardcore
stand up at first um streamlined with
that
whereas like phoebe and i come from this
sort of like multi-hyphenate like
you know producing stuff and putting
this kind of thing together and trying
that
so i think that's like a more
like a it's a more establishment thing
like
path and then also like being in la for
for
you just came straight to la like new
york it's like you're
23 for a long time and in l.a it's like
at 23 you're suddenly 65.
wild like people who you know people who
are like super famous for a long time
like
um whatever people who were child stars
you know natasha leon is like so old you
know
it was like 35 and like so young so true
i mean such an old man yeah and like
even like i don't know just like the
business makes
you older and being in la is hard it's a
particular kind of
pressure there's also like this some
really
simple things that no one bothers to
tell
uh some so for me one of the biggest
lessons i learned it took me
two specials to learn it neil brennan
had to come in
and and tell it to me uh is if you're
shooting a special
in a venue on a friday night you got to
go in the night before and turn on the
air conditioning
no one tells you that so two specials in
a row
i'm on stage you have to basically in
the beginning you don't have a lot of
money you normally have like two
or two shows a night for two nights you
pick the best you intercut them people
probably know this or you pick one
whatever
the first two were always a wash because
i was sweating
so much pit sweat face sweat i'm drip
no one told me you go in the night
before and turn on the ac
like i just no i just didn't know you
know it's like little things like that
so when i
when like phoebe would be like i'm
shooting special but you got a genetic
like i would just like
puke up all the things that i didn't
want her to have to learn the hard way
which is like probably annoying and just
feels like
but i i want to put it all like in a
document or something
yeah and like pass it out i don't know
god it's like that's a great book too
you know because like we come from the
comedy side and then
you know you've become this creator and
showrunner so there's like it gets into
tv but like it also
could get into movies like that you know
like you're saying like saying
um black owned hair products half the
half the
how you can ask for that it's easy if
you're on number one on the call sheet
or an ep
you know i see a lot of of you know
this is gonna sound pejorative i'm not
just actresses being like why aren't
there more
you know you know um uh black crew and
it's like well these decisions were made
six months ago right before you were
you know what i'm saying it's like these
are conversations to have with the line
producers
and i'm always i'm always the one that
gets you know everyone eye rolls at me
because i'm like hey i know these are
like super famous fancy actresses and
this is so great
this is going to get attention but we
need to have like conversations with the
line producers because no line producer
who actually does the
hiring crew wants to admit that they
don't know people of color they want to
hire their
friends who did a great job last time
who's going to save the money like
you know no one and you're not allowed
to ask in an email you're not allowed to
ask if someone's
of color it's illegal so it's this
tricky situation
where we're asking these people to hire
a crew that they don't know they don't
have access to
i was trying to start something on
clubhouse clubhouse i know it's like
you know it's it's you know people are
having mixed experiences on it
i've had an incredible experience like
you know being like hey
crew of color tell me what's going on
why aren't i fight why
why are what's happening and they're
going hey the union rule
is that black hair and makeup artist or
any makeup artist
they have to have 60 days on a set and
most shows now don't even shoot 60 days
so we can't even get the union so
there's union issues here
so i wouldn't like need to get that
information didn't have it you know so
and even the context of unions it took
me a long time to understand that
like what their corruption and um
[Music]
white supremacy looks like because you
think unions
or i thought initially that a union was
a progressive entity
why are writers getting paid to pitch
why aren't actors getting paid audition
they're working for free for two weeks
writers they're pitching
it's wild i would love to be paid for
pitching
it's so draining and like and you might
not get the job
right right it takes a part of your soul
every time mm-hmm
and uh it's it's but you know i wanted
to bring something up with you
uh i i i want to bring something up that
was kind of a thing i was working on and
i i tend to do some hot i know i do hot
takes
and i get in trouble but i was trying to
work on these hot tapes hot takes
i'm known for my hot takes uh uh
but i was the mansplaining thing
so when people like he's mansplaining
he's been spending i was i'm obviously
being facetious
but my thing is like they have all the
information
hilarious yeah we need them to mansplain
us so that we know
i know that mansplaining technically
means i'm explaining you something you
already know
right right but my thing is man splay me
all day right because i don't know how
to change a title but it's like man's
planning doesn't usually
well i guess neil brennan was
mansplaining about the air conditioner
and it's like thank you bro
dude thank you you patronized to me and
thank you
yeah yeah yeah yeah now i i how else am
i gonna get the information i love it
i don't need a guy i don't need a guy
walking up to me when i drive into the
grocery store being like that's a big
car for a little late lady
i don't need that shit but if you know
some shit about this cameras
tell me yeah yeah totally because i
don't know
and i'm embarrassed to ask mansplain all
you want i don't care what i love that
tone you do and see it's a hot take i
didn't want to forget to ask you so i
wrote an m and concealer on my hands
hilarious
hilarious so so i'm like split about
that where i'm like
mansplaining what that's such a funny
and concealer it's
the same as your skin color i was just
afraid that i was gonna not ask you but
so
i do also struggle with that kind of
stuff because it's like we need men
around to tell us how but what's the
question like
do i agree or something oh yeah well am
i ignorant for saying that
oh no it's fun it's funny and true it's
like and it's also like i think you're
pointing out the nuance too or it's like
men are like oh you know to talk and
it's like well just be useful
yeah and then like then fucking talk to
me the answers and tell me how to like
save and make money
yeah exactly and um uh yeah so that's
just something that i was sort of
thinking about
as i'm going like let's fire all women
and i'm like
we gotta ask right man at some point
because he's got the instructions
yep he's got the instruction manual so
we're gonna have to be
you know get it so i'm always kind of
like struggling with that
black and white thinking you know and i
think i'm excited for this to be
you know not men versus women
you know i know and it's useful versus
genuinely like diverse perspectives
help make anything better data
and experience uh a production of
whatever whatever medical shit like
whatever
um and that includes white male bodies
also my deal is the more i'm in this
business the more i'm like we need
moms it is my experience when moms come
in it is like boom boom boom it is just
they know how to balance 500 things
and there's also a stigma against moms
that we don't talk about enough where
we're like
because we don't have like the
infrastructure to right help them out
genuinely that's right um but if we did
they they moms our bosses moms are like
are you fed do you need some water i
mean every no one's hangry
do you need a nap i was just saying
yesterday on this meeting like
i just always in broad city when when we
did broad city like the
experience of being a comedian getting
to
be the creator and tell the story oh my
god the fucking dream you know whatever
um seinfeld you know
just whatever you know what i mean just
like me just going up yeah just just
like you know just like getting to have
a tv show it's just like wow i mean i
were like oh my god i thought
okay i thought you were talking about
something else no i'm saying like louis
was a
comedian who made a show yeah it's just
like you know um but we were honestly
doing it at the same time anyway
um but just like whatever the fuck you
know comedians who get yours literally
everybody loves raymond you know it's
just like they were all like 45 also
yeah and abby and i were like 24 27.
and abby and i are like oh my god this
is amazing and we're
so obsessed and we're everything we're
the showrunners and eps when we're um
rewriting all the scripts and starring
in it and editing it
and uh while why insane michelle butto
yesterday we were or sunday we were
chatting and she was like who was the
showrunner brought to you i was like
bitch bitch abby and i were like
we were it was like pulling weed out of
your pussy like guys we're gonna need to
take five
i mean insane it was insane so um
it was insane but like i think the the
gift
that we learned was like oh my gosh
you have a set you know avi was like a
camp counselor i was a babysitter and i
just like
it just felt like those vibes that's
like what taking care of a crew it's
it's the best that's as good as getting
to make the art i'm obsessed i love it
it is such a political space you know
the thing about like black-owned um
the idea of like you can't write it you
can only do disappearing voice memos to
be like
how many people of color do we have
hired and how many women you know it's
like because it's not allowed or
whatever
um because the only policies whatever
yeah you know the policy it's also we
also have to get into a place where we
can
but just so you know emily when i
interrupt she shoots me with the nerf
dart gun
and so
i'm because i'm i silence women on a
regular basis
oh my gosh that's so funny i love it
though when i have my i have my train of
thought continue
no i'm just interrupting and i got
excited and wanted to
co-sign with hilarious um well i guess
the only policy in place is like
we don't see color kind of and they're
like and we mustn't
because this is how i continue to hire
my friends i've always hired whatever
and it's like we should see color and
then we should hire to um
oh it's it's nuts so um
there's also not really a zarya database
yet that is
uh you know going on clubhouse and just
saying hey
i'm literally going are there any black
hair stylists in pensacola
i mean it's an imperfect system there's
so it's such a political space a set and
i learned how much
how exciting that is and how delicious
and i love to mother set
segwaying into my that i'm
um pregnant i'm a pregnant person
i don't hesitate to say mom yet because
it's like we'll see
you know we'll just see what happens and
i'm not we'll just see i just want to be
you know careful or whatever but this
baby does seem like they're like ready
to come out and live
they're like they're like dancing
and like doing like um i just keep
joking about all the shit they're doing
in their zumba classes soccer drills
building furniture tracy anderson river
dance
protesting marching vision boarding
it's so wild it's so insane and the way
that it's lining up with this fucking
movie is
ridiculous the movie which is about sort
of childbirth
in america and ivf yeah it's kind of
it's like uh
false positive uh we did it with 824 and
it's coming out on hulu and it's about
it's like a horror movie about how it's
a like
a patriarchal horror movie it's funny
because i was like it's a horror movie
about
giving birth in america i was like so
it's a documentary
oh my gosh it's um it's a horror movie
about how
the patriarchy is expressed through
medicine particularly pregnancy medicine
particularly particularly ivf medicine
which
is like which if you're lucky enough to
be in the one percent to even
be in that nightmare what a fucking
nightmare i
you know like again i'm i'm 33 i'll be
in april my friends are my age a little
older than me in in this business
where you know it's as i come to this
time and this birth i'm like timing it
out and i'm like well then i'll
i'll you know i'm just whatever planning
and it's like
people who um you know just ivf it's
supposed to be this empowering thing but
it's like
yet another imprisoning system for women
that affects black women more
you know it's just like another who's in
charge of it
is it's very private at the moment and
also um
you know it's a tricky one because it's
it's i'm on one hand as you know i froze
my eggs when i was i guess 33
because i very much you know biology is
sexist i was told you can have whatever
you want do whatever you want and then i
realized like
oh like i can't naturally have it
capitalism is sexist
yes yes i'm like you're more brilliant
not not more brilliant but it's like
it's a brilliant experience to have a
baby and take a fucking year off to like
i'd probably be such a better artist
frankly but i
i i learned you can't do both at once
and then i see ali wong on stage doing
stand-up and i was like
what oh my i didn't know that was an
option
i didn't think you know what i'm saying
and so what a fucking boss these women
showing like bringing your baby to a
press giant whatever it is and
you know june rayfield on the set of uh
uh grayson frankie was like no i'm
breastfeeding
it's it's i'm not on camera i can do my
off-camera coverage while breast like
figuring out a system that that kind of
works i was told you're
pregnant with a kid or you're working
there is no in between
and also like i just think about you and
your like
whole upbringing and shit too it's just
like you had to be very self-sufficient
so like
no shit that you thought you had to be
you had to over correct
you know what i mean had to over correct
and i think i also
you know my perfection my emotional
perfectionism which
is you know perfectionism leads to
procrastination which leads to paralysis
and i think you know
we artists women people of color because
we've always had to be twice as good to
get half as far
perfectionism is so intense that i was
like i have to be the perfect mom and i
have to have
the perfect time we're all going to make
mistakes we're going to fuck up
i look back at my mom and i'm like she
was never there
and that was my story then i looked back
and i'm like she took me to work with
her every day
i saw a woman working all the time i
i oh my god i felt rejected and like you
know she worked at uh in a mall
bloomingdale so i was like in a mall all
day and i was like bored and i want to
be but i was watching a woman hustle
so i kind of victimized myself
and was like i didn't have a mom that
made me dinner every night at seven i
look back and i'm like i'm so lucky that
i got to see a working mom
yep you know so i also had to rewrite my
story of it being a trauma
and go like that was fucking awesome
yeah you know so i also like was scared
to have a kid for the longest time
because i was like
i don't want to fuck this up and be
badass totally totally
i have that too but like i don't know
i'll just figure it out as i go and i
feel like i do feel
i have mamilani vibes you know like i'm
like i feel
uh confident in my intuition or
i'm like i know i should just be more
confident in my instincts
and in general i like you know and my
partner and i planned this and thought
about it and talked about it
yeah you yeah we were like we really
could not really could
not did you think about a surrogate
which i believe are illegal in
uh uh new york for some reason is that
true with michelle but i think
yeah i think correct
why i don't know also a lot of this ivf
stuff is not covered by insurance
there are some companies that are
starting to cover it because there are
times that ivf
or egg freezing or whatever is if a
woman has cancer you know there's a
this woman um uh andrea rice someone
rice
who you know had cancer at a young age
and her insurance wouldn't cover her
freezing her eggs while she was going
through chemo or whatever you know
there's very real reasons
medical reasons that women you know may
want to do this to make sure they can
have natural childbirth or do it later
or whatever but it's just like fuck you
like you're deciding what's legitimate
about
my choice to birth or not it's so
fucking rude
and it's like um my friend was
uh left this big company that she like
helped build into
so such an insanely wealthy company
and she cobras the insurance now she's
no longer working there
and she just we were like doing a call
about something and she got
a call in the middle of it and found out
she actually doesn't have to
front this like 15 000 extra dollars she
thought she would for the ivf
because the insurance covers it because
she
created that policy while she was at the
company stop
and that's like a big part of my
experience with
this movie false positive is like would
you help write
yeah my my director john lee and i wrote
the
script and um the thing that
like you know we went from he had this
like sort of
idea and mood about it but then
together we made it like a feature you
know a feature structure
were you scared to do like coming from
like this
like hysterical show that's like gifts
it's like half the gifts i get are you
[Laughter]
i feel like we're so much closer i was
like a lot of just texting i'm like no
this is a chain
someone is sending me a picture of her
like doing something funny
like i'll be like want to go to dinner
it's you being like yes and i'm like am
i having dinner with alana
like you know this this incredibly
like huge comedy like and you know i
feel like people like jordan peele are
showing like
we can do more than one thing like doing
a horror movie first time was that like
daunting i wasn't scared when i was
making it because i like jump into shit
i love to jump into shit which is like
kind of how i feel with this baby even
though we like
really thought about it for a while and
decided to do it i still it still feels
like i'm like diving into something
but um but i wasn't scared while i was
doing it i'm like nervous now that it's
coming out i'm like holy shit
like people are gonna see how like sick
i am
awesome yeah and i'm like even this i'm
like diving into the experience of
making it outward-facing and it's just
like you know what the fuck
i can't very analysis where i'm just
like i'm just going to contain myself
in it and exp you know feel what i feel
and
pay attention to the feelings what the
fuck else can i do and also like
learning in public so
a lot of things i mean podcasting i have
no idea what i'm doing every time i
leave here i'm like i don't
it's it's it used to be comedians would
have
20 years to do the road and now we're
kind of learning in public
and when people are like hey you talk
too fast i'm like i know i'm still
learning this
i couldn't do it like it's probably as
i'm doing the podcast kind of under the
radar this is an indie podcast i do
myself because i'm like
i don't feel like i know how to do this
you know i'm taking these risks and i'm
still learning
how to do it which also like when you
talk about producing other people's
podcasts it's um
i bet you would you know like say i did
this thing with indy and i'm like will
you
produce this with me or for me it's like
that's actually would be great for you
to do the
like white collar version of it let's
say let's say this is the blue color
version you're doing it
because um to transfer what you've
learned
is different and different than the
thing we were talking about before of
being like
you should take off at eight and then
you're working until midnight you know
it's
it's different i pretended to leave and
come back
i believe it do it all the time i
fucking believe it um
but yeah you you should produce others
because i i hear you about it feeling
messy but um
it's so good and there's also think
thank you
and um but also there's this and i'm
gonna
whatever fuck it like a lot of these
companies that are having podcast deals
with people
are taking 40 percent of the back it's
cr it's crazy i know i
i like they're paying you're paying an
agent you're paying a manager you're
paying a lawyer and then you're giving
for you're not
you know it's it's this is a new
iteration of packaging which is sort of
a very criminal thing that was happening
in hollywood for a very long
time we don't want to ask questions
we're lucky to be here we're caught like
you know and we sign it's like student
loans you sign you don't know where
you're signing
you don't know what you're signing and
then you're in a situation where you
don't own your shit
you're paying commission for the rest of
your life to somebody that wasn't even
involved in help like there's just
a lot of stuff that i was really like
scared to do but
as business people we have to and then i
also looked at what the guys were doing
i was like i asked questions to the guys
and i was like hey do you pay an agent
for this stupid and they're like
no and i was like what the fuck man yep
i know you guys may
not know this about us but all three of
us are professional athletes
what's your sport ben my sport ribbon
dancing
it's an olympic sport and killing it
uh emily what's your professional
wrestle uh what's that thumb wrestling
thumb wrestling and i'm a bottom
uh so i have to be honest with you
this is a very sincere moment and i'm
not even joking when you get athletic
greens to sponsor your podcast i'm not
even joking that means you've made it
she's not even joking guys i'm not even
joking she's not joking i'm not joking
uh and i'm really i've been waiting for
athletic greens
to come hither for a while now and we
have athletic greens as a sponsor
i'll tell you what it is i'm happy too
because i'm i'm ready for you to stop
scooping into your mouth
just powder form but honestly this stuff
has kept me alive i actually found out
about it from alana glazer
like two years ago she told me about it
and i started buying it and then um
uh it's basically i just put it in like
a cup of water and it's every like
vitamin you need
one tasty scoop of athletic greens
contains 75 vitamins minerals and whole
food source
ingredients look at including
multivitamins multi-minerals probiotics
greens superfood blends and more they
all work together
to fill the nutritional gaps in your
diet increase energy and focus aid with
digestion and support a healthy immune
system
all without the need to take multiple
products like
i was taking nine and i also gag on
pills i can't do a
vitamin like those vitamins you know i
mean like like this is just you can put
it in water drink it you're done put it
in your sport
pack yeah i put it right in my gatorade
bottle wait what's no what's the thing
that's a water bottle that squeezes like
sports people
squeezable gatorade bottles i know but
no no no water bottle no yeah
yeah what you know that different than
what i said
you know you know what mma a juice box
mma fighters they
spray just a regular water water squeeze
you just need something that squeezes
the smart model right right
bottle but put it in your squirt bottle
and you get them all look at this i put
my athletic greens
in my smoothie and i mix it up it's
right there look at that yeah gorgeous
who's jealous you jealous and look
that's i'm glowing
my skin my hair grows this could be you
i'm healthy simply visit
athleticgreens.com
whitney and join health experts athletes
health care crunches
around the world who make a daily
commitment to all health
every day again simply visit
athleticgreens.com
whitney and get your free year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packs
today
you didn't flub it but you didn't read
the right words you have to eat a bean
yes i didn't read the right roads
because i had to rewrite it anyways
because they were up in the middle of
the green part and we can't wrap in the
green part
so you should read it or if
you go ahead do it without on your head
what's that okay simply
do it as i throw beans at you oh yeah
simply visit athletic cleans
again right off the bat all right i
already had a
bad b oh no this actually does stop down
production
too much we have spoiled milk these
these beans are
i think whitney can't have them
they're for ages 4 and up
simply visit athleticgreens.com whitney
and join health experts athletes and
health conscious go-getters around the
world who make a daily commitment to
their health every day
again simply visit athletic greens.com
whitney and get your free year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packets
today
whitney's back ugh why do i always get
the fuck i don't know
you need to stop doing them because it's
dealing them i feel
was that uh no uh we heard it yeah we
heard it loud and clear i don't think we
did
[Music]
um
we were harmonizing and you dropped it
no i thought you did a great job i
thought that was the introduction to the
next part yeah but you left me hanging
and you let my sing bomb
i didn't i can't sing over because you
got jealous i don't know i know i know
you think that people should just sing
over each other but i was giving you a
moment
i thought you harmonized that's what i'm
doing when i interrupt people i'm
harmonizing a conversation
and you want them to talk in sync like
the twins and the shining guys i saw a
really sweet comment the other day that
was like whitney's only interrupting
because she hasn't done stand-up in so
long and we all need to relearn social
behaviors
i'm interrupting you i'm interrupting
all of you to talk about super coffee
it's an indulgent healthy ready to drink
alternative sugary coffee drinks
it's keto friendly it's lactose free
it's gluten free honestly it's delicious
i'm holding this up okay
i am such so addicted to coffee this has
saved me so much time because i'm like
all the rigmarole of like
i wake up and i like have to get and
where's the little cuppy thing that goes
in the thing and the
water has to go in the maker and it's
like in the morning i can't
with that it's like a nightmare so this
you just pick it up and you drink it but
i
um uh it's got fats in it and it's got
like all this healthy
stuff in it so that you don't have to
also it comes in like
canned shots it comes in this uh i like
the vanilla
yummy i love this i'm obsessed there's
like ground versions of it
i mean there's like all the versions of
coffee you want they have them yeah and
it's like you notice it also
uh when i make like coffee on my own
it's like it gets cold and there's and
then i'm out of the sugar and i'm out of
the thing and all the stuff
this is all in there well it's funny you
mentioned sugar because in 2020 alone
super coffee removed over 600 million
grams of sugar from american diet
zero grams added sugar 10 grams of
protein from your coffee
and uh 200 milligrams of caffeine but i
never feel
it's sweetened with monk fruits yeah and
they have a creamer
did you have the creamer is no fantastic
why don't we have that
in the fridge oh oh wow monk fruit
notable investors include jennifer lopez
that's the only only one i want
well this makes me look like jennifer
lopez a-rod
and another a-rod aaron rodgers aaron
rodgers and aaron like who
my brother's not law's two is it two is
it two let's go back to jennifer lopez
okay
um 60 day money back guarantee meaning
if you don't love it you get your money
back
and it was featured on shark tank let's
support sharks look at that oh did a
shark tank person come up with this i
love that by three brothers jordan jake
and jim
are any of you single oh
we love your coffee but also emily needs
a husband so call us
i was gonna wink but i stopped i'll
learn to stop winking okay emily let's
do the let's do the
green let's see what you got we've
worked out an exclusive deal for the
good for you podcast listeners receive
off plus free shipping on any of their
best-selling variety packs
this is a great way to try all their
delicious flavors go to
drinksupercoffee.com
whitney or use codewhitney at checkout
to claim this deal that's d-r-i-n-k
s-u-p-e-r see now thank you
you messed up emily has to eat a bee not
a blue bee
no you're
wait a minute stop i'm eating all the
blue beans right emily no don't
emily's a cheater okay what are you
doing right now hold on this is going to
stop stuff down
i'm not going to not be dramatic about
this so buckle up i ate all the
blueberries
are they all so they're all okay that
thank you benton
that was i uh i was doing great and then
somebody's
gonna ruin my super coffee taste it is
okay okay
emily's eating him what fake that's a
shaky sock
the stinky socks smells just like emily
got a stinky sock
that's close to having a man
[Laughter]
[Music]
whitney you read the green we worked out
an exclusive deal for the well we're
keeping that okay sorry this is a great
way we've worked out an inclusive deal
for a good free podcast listeners
received 25
off plus free shipping on any of their
best-selling variety packs this is a
great way to try all their delicious
flavors go to
use code drinksupercoffee.com to check
out for this deal that's
g-r-i-n-k-s-u-p-e-r-c-o-f-f-e-e dot com
whitney super coffee is also available
nationwide and over 25 000 stores like
target whole foods walmart kroger and
cvs
come through brothers uh at emily noonan
on instagram
or whatever the fuck her thing is knock
me up okay
um i'm obsessed with watching uh
documentaries because
it makes me feel like i've read a book
you're also obsessed with comedy so this
is a good one
i am obsessed with comedy me too i love
this is right up my alley
every time i drive by the billboard i'm
like look at that look at that look at
that emily was very annoyed oh that
there was
because there's a documentary about
women in comedy yeah called
hysterical it's on fx i mean the fact
that people
this is frankly touching to me
that this has been made who touched you
so many
lucky i just feel like a lot of my uh
friends are like discovering all these
female comedians now and i'm like yeah
they've been funny for a while now you
just haven't seen them and this
documentary is so cool because like
they're kind of all in one place you're
like who do you think i was hanging out
with to hide from you
all these women yes and like you know i
think the podcasts have shown like
people want to hear
women's stories and what it's like
behind the scenes as a female comic and
what was like coming up
and um how we've been pitted against
each other and how audiences
you know uh i mean i used to go on stage
and when they
the the um host would be like so are you
guys ready for a lady
you know and then that would be the cue
for everyone to go use the bathroom
aside from all that beautiful story
and all of these important facts that
you just mentioned there's also a lot of
really funny jokes in it it's also just
funny so do you like to laugh
funniest women in comedy they are
talking about their struggles
um their personal stories their opinions
um uh it was directed by an academy
award nominated an emmy-winning director
andrea
nevins gangster um who doesn't love this
comedy yes opinions women
walking backwards yes if you guys
whatever if you
like me or listening to this at all like
us like just watch check it out it
should
this is like a no-brainer this episode
is brought to you by the fx original
documentary hysterical hysterical
premiere is friday april 2nd at 9 00 pm
on fx streaming next day on fx and hulu
streaming next day fx on hulu
i like dipped my toe into it and it was
just like checking out a few um
a few different companies and i was like
you take
50 for a podcast it just
didn't make sense and then what's hot is
like uh
you should just we should just talk
about it because you're just starting
your own thing then it's like
you just have this whole um you know
like
uh jake and amir or whatever they now
have like their own whole company yeah
amazing
so it's like they i imagine they started
independently and then have
a company yeah which i think you could
easily do
um i want to talk about easily but
remember baby
wait let me just say this one thing so
the thing i just wanted to say is
so like when we made it the feature
structure john lee
and i like there's like a big like
at the end and the thing about
ivf is that women are not
protected about it around it
because you have to be in the place of
policy making
to make policy it's changing now that
we're seeing like butoh and andy cohen
like
how they kind of represented it and they
went to albany about it like i think
artists are understanding that they can
also be activists activists are becoming
like
the foremost policymakers you know black
lives matter is like
is like showing how to make policy
out of activism and then people are so
it's not just performative
tweeting for likes it's like i'm going
down and i'm gonna i get a bill passed
like
you're actually right and there's this
like sort of pipeline and also um
indivisible do you know indivisible it's
this grassroots
huge nationwide network of um
activists that like started in with the
trump resistance and now they're
running for office with you know like
run for something is a great
organization it's like
there's this pipeline emerging and as
toxic as social media is and as
as toxic as social media can be and can
feel i also see this like optimal
version where it is like raising our
consciousness such that we're
taking the system back so anyway this
like for false positive like
the biggest horror about the medical
system and pregnancy and ivf and
surrogacy is that
there's no product protection for
pregnant people
we have to like learn the horrors be
traumatized
and then spend decades creating policy
um to protect the next generation
because it like then no longer even
really applies to the initial person
who's traumatized did you feel like some
kind of um
like when my dad died i felt this like
biological i was always like i'm gonna
adopt i'm gonna get foster kids which
i'm sure i'm gonna do at some point it's
so
like part of my like me i wanna adopt
foster kids from west virginia like it's
just in
my blood that's like where my roots are
that's where you grew up west virginia
western washington dc roanoke virginia
and west virginia in the summers place
my my best friend int grew up in
morgantown no this psychiatrist i'm
talking about no way
and he's so it's so tell no no way
he is a gorgeous brilliant like elegant
he's just my i just um he
he's just my i love him he probably grew
up drinking poisonous water
so there were chemical spills in that
area i'm i would love to
i would love to talk to him the way coal
companies have come in i mean it's like
so there's lots of foster kids and the
opiate that is literally the
the heart and soul of the opioid crisis
is morgantown
the koch brothers own morgantown you
know and um
it is very much my dream to go but i
want to rebuild the hotel my dad managed
like that's my home
to get jobs in there and you know
whatever so um but when your dad passed
when my dad passed i had this biological
like
urge to uh have my own kid
that was like all consuming and then as
soon as i froze my eggs i felt
this maybe it was just i was getting
older just like
i'm gonna save the environment like once
you're
you're no longer a kid anymore when you
have a cat right so there's also this
um obligation of i have to fix the world
before this thing gets here
because i don't want my kid growing up
without water yeah
like do you feel does that overwhelm you
i don't know i'm like
there's part of me that wants to
[Music]
solve the world's problems and then
there's like part of me that um
i mean i can't and i can do a little bit
i can do one human body's worth
over the course of my lifetime and
my my husband just said to me today
you're everybody's mommy
because i like i sometimes want to be
that and i want to be everybody's mommy
and make them feel you know like good
and this
that and it's like yeah i can shit on it
and be and be like women we think we
have to xyz but it's like
it's actually just transcendent of
identity politics and just a feeling
that is natural to me of like
taking care of people and it feels good
um yeah it's not an obligation it's just
uh yeah and sometimes it's an obligation
but it's also
sometimes just a natural instinct of
mine
but like we were we both we talked about
it for
a couple years um my husband's name is
david we talked about it for a long time
and it's like
you know like for i think people tom
segura had a great joke
about when he like first had his first
trial then his like special was like
everybody's like
it's so selfless it's so selfless he's
like it's so fucking selfish
you're like look how cute they are and
it looks like you
and it was so funny and it's like you
know this idea that we tell ourselves
well
we'll have children and they'll make the
world a better place it's so gross and
it's like
don't put that on kids you know like do
it yourself
or do the best you can or clean up our
mess oh
and and it's like we all have the baby
boomers like mess of plastic to clean up
like there's no
more of a mess to really we should stop
that mess and then
we all gotta figure out how the fuck to
do it or if you're not gonna figure it
out like
shut the fuck up and and go away but
like you know i think
for us there's like an awareness of like
we're having this
this baby as um a decision we made for
ourselves
we wanted this experience as a as a pair
um were you scared of this is this is
a very gross question great and i like i
love gross yeah i love just means human
i think we are so good
oh yeah i need to stop conflating human
and gross i had those
let's see how gross it is do you have
any i have the i'm embarrassed that i
have this
i like to admit my disgusting thoughts
do you feel any like i'm going to fall
behind
totally totally i'm like um
racing toward this deadline of birth
right now
and i'm trying to have things to put a
pin in such that
then my um producing partner kelsey
and my like generator the my
sort of non-profit platform glennis my
partner there
can work in i'm talking about quarters
i'm like two three i'm going to be down
what i'd love is to have the momentum
keep going and then i come back 100
fall behind yeah but like i think also
there have been so many
um pregnant people
and women and moms and parents that i've
heard in the last 10 years talk about
that feeling
such that i don't know it's like i
i do have that feeling but then it's
also like i think it's just a feeling
it's irrational it's completely
irrational and let me tell you also
incorrect because when i see moms come
back
they work more efficiently they work
faster they have somewhere to be they
actually get more done in a less amount
of time
and because the way your brain changes
and the way you can sort of you know so
i have yet to see that happen to someone
it's an irrational fear i have no proof
it's like a story that i was told myself
or
and it was so it was told to you so long
ago and so
many times that it's like encoded in
your
genes and so it's hard to like tease out
but i think maybe it's an excuse i'm
making because i'm scared or don't have
the guy or
you know whatever you know i gotta look
at at the shit that i
say to uh because i'm in denial or
defensive or whatever i
i'm also like i'm always doing doing
doing going going going
you know after broad city ended we like
finished 50 episodes we did
all those roles all those rules just
abby and me like doing all that fucking
shit rewriting every episode
five passes you know it's like we wrote
250 scripts for that show
wild like you know it's just like and
cutting for this and just being squeezed
and i know the budget you had on that i
know the kind of budget you had on that
job yeah and it's not like and the
feedback and the standards and practices
this was before
this wasn't like youtube and tick tock
where people do whatever
you had people tell me if i'm wrong 100
correct you got to think of a new word
for this like just obstacle after
obstacle
oh it's so crazy and it's like after
that i um
uh made this movie then and
then went on tour did my first special
and after that was then when i was like
um
i'm going to work from 11 to 7 and not
on weekends
and it's been you know messy but i've
been
trying to have some semblance of that
but anyway
like i'm doing doing doing going
plotting and planning
so much that i also think that this time
off is going to be this
period where i let things come to me
and i chase and i don't do that i i
never
do that and can i just say something
really quick that just please
you're not i mean it's not interrupting
please but because you're saying this
time off but i always like to tell
people
when women take maternity leave it's not
time off
i you're saying it that's fine but it's
very often i have to tell
people at work when uh a mom comes back
well she's been off for three months
like she wasn't off
right that wasn't a vacation right yeah
i mean
it's like when um a friend of mine's
husband
was like you know i can't babysit our
kid tonight and she's like it's not
babysitting it's called parenting
words are important yeah and it's a
different you know what i mean so i
always am like
that is so funny and i guess it's like i
what i mean is you're
totally corrected it's not off you're
like not sleeping the same and all that
shit but
just this like period of like life only
i'm really like don't call me unless you
wanna
like just talk love hate
loss you know like i'm really i'm
i i do think while part of me is a
little bit like i'm gonna fall behind
i'm gonna build these structures such
that they stand when i'm not there and
then i'm gonna come back and there will
be an engine it's like
i'm also just so um you're
not you're growing during that time as
an artist that's what everyone during
the pandemic and like i'm falling behind
and
it's like dude you can grow as an artist
even when you're not on stage
we can be writing and living for art to
imitate life we have to have a life
i remember being in a writer's room on a
tv show
and someone pitched an idea they're like
well what if the character like goes to
a baby shower
on sunday and i was like people don't go
to baby showers
and they're like no you don't
like i could i didn't have a life to
draw from yeah
people are like pitching like and then
they go to picnic and i'm like okay like
that happens in france
right right you know what i mean like i
couldn't even be a good writer
yeah you're like what are you fucking
yogi beer
bitch we got a fucking picnic i know
like i was living yoga
like i was living on a set with this
fake life and fake people and
you know that's the thing also that's
like
it there there is something that i
really like la
it's really enjoyable we've i mean look
at this
and we've been here for like six months
david and i and it's we've just had such
a nice time and actually
covet la has been terrifying but also
um it's like
we don't have to go every anywhere and i
don't have to drive to three places
with like an hour 15 drive and park time
in between
it's been so much better to do
everything on zoom
then you like step outside and you're
like oh my gosh it's like so sunny here
or whatever
i think the zoom stuff will stay for
good good detail it's
speak it into truth and talk about the
environment we used to drive an
hour to meet a director for a job we
pro that was probably already offered to
catherine hahn let's be honest
and it like halfway through you're
realizing you're like on a weird date
why am i at a hotel
and then an hour that's three hours of
my time
for he'll keep you in mind for the next
thing
or whatever it was like rose it's just
like zooms it's like you're in you're
out there's no small talk you're not
talking about like you know bullshit
it's just like we're getting in we're
getting out i'm off like yeah it is
i think it'll say slash i'm going to
make it stay
for myself and how about this pay your
employees the amount of money you were
spending on that ridiculous
uh office space that overhead goes down
and now you pay your employees more
yep yep and they might have kids and can
say whatever
yeah 100 i um so i've really enjoyed it
however
just what you're saying about like real
life it's just it is harder here being
that this is the
one industry city one industry town
where i'm like this is like feels like
almost um
in my mind like you know the auto
industry in detroit
in the 50s but like you clock and clock
out for like tv and film
and like you know it's different like
broad city was like this like
freaking passion like abby and i put our
like
you know every color of the rainbow
inside of ourselves on
on this show you know it's different
here there's there is a more factory
mentality in a way that i like where i'm
like
it's just a fucking job okay
but like in new york it's like such um
bang for your buck for like seeing
insane shit and experiencing shit
that um it's weird like the
you know how it's so prescribed i
understand why
you were like baby shower because it's
like i don't know
like stand up when you're in a writer's
room stand up feels like real life still
fucking work it's still fucking like
producing and
you know but a writer's room really
feels factory compared to the
freedom of standup um but also in the
right you know out here
you know there are people writers that
are writers for hire
you know there is now a thing where
people are like i'm going to write my
show and star in it it's just there used
to be like you were a writer and every
year you got paid more money and you
went from this show to this show and
this
you know what i mean it was like those
days are kind of
you know it was like when i couldn't
find um
any young people to direct multicam it
was like there's the people that do
multicam they've been doing it forever
and there was no new people getting into
these sort of like traditional
you know mediums and not to say that
there should be
but there was just sort of this why does
this crew only look like this it's like
well there's no one new being trained
totally it was just like a wild there's
200 people that can do this like the
studio will approve
right right right right right like i i
it's reminding me of this conversation i
had with um
a former agent of mine when like these
sag
negotiations were being poorly
negotiated and it was like
you know for streaming services it's
like character actors and she she told
me this like character actors
used to make a living now it airs once
that's it
and it's like and then they the
streaming like owns everything it's
it's um yeah it's like there's this
i think illusion of freedom but
basically we just need universal
healthcare and then it won't be like
disgusting then every single interest
industry won't be fucking disgusting
people who give birth should get a year
off everybody should have access to and
i i know i know like
it's not you know the the government um
service healthcare isn't
uh amazing in europe and people still
pay for private and that's still the
premium health care
totally however like that's my
the insurance companies are in place
that i
like we could innovate that and make
government health care
fucking sick here and you know you're
way more educated about this than i am
i can't really talk about this in a way
where i'm like able to say this is what
you do go down and register and this is
the
the you know vote on you know you know
prop this and this i'm i'm
not educated about that uh enough to
speak about it but
healthcare for that person that you
don't know
who works at rite aid who you think is
so much different than you it's
it's benefits you we are one organism
the planet is an organism and we're just
like a cell
we're one fucking cell we're an organism
and that's why like it doesn't feel good
that
native americans were genocided
in this country it doesn't feel good
that black people are still experiencing
a
long drawn-out holocaust doesn't feel
good
for everybody even a white racist who is
a
you know i mean and then they'll be like
i'm not racist or whatever but it's like
you're not chilling you're forming an
ulcer you're constipated you're angry
you're red you're red in the face it's
just like
we all feel that shit and like even if
somebody didn't care
that um you know these like immigrant
children were stuck at the border in
cages even if someone was like denying
deny
didn't feel good to know that that was
and is still happening but they're
trying to like process it through and
get these kids back or whatever but it's
like
we're one organism we're not we're not
um
we're a single fucking organism and
that's why it's like and this is a
backwards way to get to it obviously but
when people get confused i want to go
like what would you say if i said this
benefits you
like it's almost like because you know
you know we're wired to be selfish
so many people are in so much fear and
have so many problems and are like i
can't worry about other people i got to
worry about myself
and but whatever narrative you have uh
uh
i think it just helps sometimes when
it's talking about like inclusivity
riders and
and hiring women and stuff like that
like maybe blah blah blah
bad business this is about feelings and
not i'm like
you actually it's been proven that your
company will be more profitable the more
diverse it is
just do it as a mercenary capitalist if
you have to be
selfish about it you know um uh movies
written by uh people of color with these
they're making money
don't do it because you feel sorry for
them or that you're trying to look
progressive it's actually the best
business move
right you know and i think sometimes you
know bridesmaids like
they weren't like we want to give women
a chance it's they did
incredibly huge numbers right they
didn't start giving women movies because
they felt bad for them
right it's because the fucking was a
huge hit yeah sexist city was a huge hit
they were like oh we should put women in
movies turns out they go to movies
right black panther was a huge hit no
one's making movies with black leads
because they
feel bad didn't black panther make a
billion dollars
and white people were like whoa and it's
still like should we put black people in
this movie like dude
i thought you were a selfish greedy
person right be greedy about it yep
yep it's just good business yeah you
know what i'm saying it's like we're not
this isn't
we're not doing this for a chair yes
there's certain uh representation with
the sake of representation all that
stuff
great but also um it just makes more
money
and entertainment is only expanding i
think that the more experienced people
have just the more entertainment that
can be made we're
already like cock choking on fucking
content it's like
it's just gonna grow and grow and grow
and every state is going to have
you know pensacola or whatever like it's
just like well the fl honestly the miami
and florida
uh tv scene is expanding is it you know
it's like
everywhere i think every state is gonna
have uh
an expanding booming i i feel it's gonna
have a
expanding booming tv and film situation
but also like
and this is i know i'm i'm i'm probably
perceived as like negative and
and caustic about a lot of stuff but i'm
actually like weirdly
uh positive sometimes maybe the point of
naive about
some like social media like i know
there's lots of problems whatever but
it's also it's like
we're able to find like nail artists in
detroit like in in
in schenectady new york like these p
there are talented sort of people
everywhere and i think the days of you
have to be in new york or l.a are kind
of over
totally finding talent because the new
yorker la model
is you already have to have probably
come from a family with money
you already have to be able to afford to
move to l.a in new york and live in
those
it's already cutting out so many people
that we want to work with like there's
so many obstacles to even
being in the mix you know and i think
that
i'm optimistic too and it feels like so
stupid well no it doesn't it just feels
like um
i was like hysterically crying yesterday
at this at my like final laob
appointment i've had such a good
experience here
and i don't know you're gonna miss your
ob truly and umob
appointments it's like i don't need
please record them i need them in new
york but i was like
so overwhelmed like the time that i've
been here like the
you know biden is not the savior he's
got to be pushed but just like trump was
such a
dis is such a disgusting person and
republicans are it's such a disgusting
entity a disgusting entity like that
needs to be
underlined like they're just anti-human
disgusting values and
the fact that we like changed um offices
and the senate and like also
the lucas brothers i can't i mean i
can't
best six nominations they've been like
obsessed with lucas brothers who
appeared in a one
the female brain as a window washer
i love it you gave them their stuff you
know they were already i was big fans
yeah yeah i actually apologize to them
all the time i'm like sorry about that
no no no that's so fucking amazing
like i just like their nominations came
in it's just like
and i was just like in the bathroom i'm
like keeping kidding
it's just like i i do feel optimistic i
really do and i think like
you know it's also like social media is
um
you know zuckerberg like yikes instagram
is his
and yet and and the algorithms in
all these um big tech companies that are
super racist
and all that shit and yet still like
it's a really useful um
communication tool that i think i really
think that
we could figure out like the i it
sounds maybe crazy but i really think we
could every good every
idea sounds crazy until it's not i think
we can figure out like the fucking
carbon levels by 2050
i think we can like stop
i do think that there's a chance for it
and not because of relying on
gen z as a millennial i'm like i think
we can do it
aoc is a millennial you know it's like
the i just think that like the
it's just like it has to benefit you
know it's like um
you know uh getting people to stop
smoking because of secondhand smoke
never works
you know what i'm saying getting people
to stop smoking because you go hey you
know how much money you could save a
year if you stopped
you know what i mean and then you know i
think sometimes it's it's it's
balancing our utopian ideals
with surrendering and accepting human
nature
which is inherently you know can be
selfish
and when fear is present our iq
literally goes down
you know we get dumber when we're scared
and when we are worried about money we
get dumber we make uh less logical
decisions you know so we are
we're animals we're scared animals and
we're running around
you know um in our making a lot of uh
fear-based decisions so i think it's
always just like balancing like
you know i get why people in the middle
of nowhere have guns i get why they
think they
i get it i get how they're like it takes
40 minutes for i have two kids
i have a wife and it'll take 40 minutes
for a police
west virginia if they even come if i
don't even have wi-fi to call i
get how people make certain decisions
when they're scared and
i think it's always like balancing that
and you have always been someone that
i've like
like i do look at a lot of people's
activism on social media oh my god jesus
christ like this is embarrassing like
this is embarrassing
this is like as a hollywood person i'm
embarrassed and you knowing i learned
from you so much on there and i'm just
like just repost alana just repost
that's the thing about learning in
public you know like it's not like i was
just like talking about this
in the past couple days like it's not
like i'm like quietly working in a soup
kitchen
on sundays you know what i mean like i'm
i it is a public thing
my my um advocacy and activism
it is um but i'm just like the
the most currency i have is my platform
so i do think that learning um publicly
and breaking shit down simply
is the best i can do and it's like
it it bleeds into my life i can do it
most consistently what i actually wanted
to say about like healthcare whenever
you have a question a big thing
that we say at generator is is
indivisible which is this it's there
they're such a um
incredible uh grassroots activism
platform and they're constantly working
on
oh dope they're constantly working on um
policy and getting uh the correct
progressives elected locally so
everyone elections why why do i think
it's annoying it's not sexy it's lame
i never saw my parents vote in local
like i just never saw it
oh my god you're saying everything why
do i not know when it is
why do i not know how like why do i not
know anything about this this is the big
ass like um you're unlike horny to
solve this problem um through this i've
pretended i've voted in the local
elections i haven't i'm too and
like couldn't tell you go to indivisible
their
their um website put your zip code in
find the one that you like and then just
dm them
and just ask them questions that's to me
for generator we say minimal civic
engagement is what we're trying to raise
the bar
off the floor from zero i'm embarrassed
so am i
i'm embarrassed so if i go here i don't
have to be embarrassed
yeah and then why would i know yeah and
and these people know and are more
inclined
to they're they're naturally drawn to
know this shit and if they don't know
they'll point to the person who does
and um instead of complaining for the
four years that i don't have what i
want how about i take that 20 minutes to
just do it
and like black lives matter has so many
chapters across the country that if
you're interested
in racial equality and intersectional
feminism that's who you go to
indivisible is more about elections and
politicians and locally
so i'm just like it is embarrassing but
dm your local
indivisible and by the way it's like i
don't know where my dmv is i don't know
where about you know yeah i don't know
where a lot of things
right and i figure it out it's a hassle
but this this this entitled thing of i
want to live in a democracy but i don't
want to have to go to a website for five
minutes
yeah you have to pick one yep you can't
complain that your voice was not heard
and you also were like oh but i have to
log it like
and in the same way that you like love
when people are like wait should i do my
business manager and retainer or five
percent and you're
you know you have the answers for it
these people want to give the answers
right this is what they do you don't
need to know all of it
you know you need to know as much as you
need to know to participate or whatever
but
you know i need to point out you know
you're my own it's like a title
entitlement or error it's like i have to
go down to a school and wait in line
yeah
like i'm so important i just spent 40
minutes on instagram i'm looking at
wedding dresses and i'm not engaged
which you could do online at the local
collection and it's happened 40 minutes
time
it won't even be 40. you know what i
mean you know yeah we have time there's
we have time totally
that's so funny you know what i'm saying
like i was just on my ex's instagram for
two hours i have time
yeah yeah and you could just do that you
could um double fist yeah i mean like
uh vote indivisible but actually i don't
have time i gotta go
she has to go and i have to pee so bad
the fact that the pregnant woman is
doing fine
and i'm about to piss myself is super
embarrassing well i was lucky enough
that you peed in front of me twice
i will pee in front of you and show you
my pregnant boobs
oh my god my pregnant titties they are
they're more pregnant than the belly oh
my gosh
a hub zest i um i always end these very
awkwardly
hilarious abruptly abruptly i love that
me too
and thank you for not letting me
pathologize and so abruptly is better
than awkwardly because awkward is a
judgment on myself it wasn't even my
intention although i'm glad that was a
byproduct
and that is the form in which my
awkwardness takes which is abrupt
transition so i totally get it
obsessed with you um individual uh uh
false positive is gonna be out on hulu's
yes uh june 25th can not wait i love you
don't write elephants uh uh uh follow
not you that's i say that only um
uh and you you guys know what to do
you're adults you've heard podcasts love
you
i love you thank you for having me
you're so brilliant your
your mind is on fire that's amazing love
you as is your heart
come on okay i hope i didn't rub too
much i tried really hard you guys don't
be bad
four four four five
you